I was just thinking about you and the
former president in your own house like
is he is he driving you crazy are you
like take out the trash I mean it's a
little dependent being yet the white hat
one of the keys to a successful marriage
is separate bathrooms Michelle Obama
revealing the hilarious secret to making
her marriage to husband Barack work
especially now that they're out of the
White House when he enters my bathroom
sometimes I'm like why are you in here
no and he's like I live here can I enjoy
my bathroom too but he's been good we've
both been busy we're working on books so
that keeps us busy and we've got kids in
college one kid in college one on the
way so we've got a senior in high school
so it's all the drama that goes with et
was with Michelle in 2015 right before
Malia started college she said she and
Barack were preparing for empty nest
syndrome black and I we spend most
weekends we're staring at each other cuz
somebody's at a basketball game
somebody's at a dance
somebody's sleeping over we're the last
people our kids want to be with so I
think they're conditioning us for that
empty nest syndrome but we're gonna you
know we're not relishing that at all
so I don't know what we're gonna do I
got to get him some more hobbies the
former first lady ELLs have said she
still has no plans to run for office I
want to serve I want to do work I want
to be out there but there are so many
ways to make an impact politics is just
not my thing it's as simple as that
[Music]